hello everyone this is Amir from audio
science review I have a second episode
of my uh review Roundup last week a
little bit late today's Tuesday I was
supposed to do this on the weekend
anyway
um I did one episode of this and
feedback was generally positive
um so let's do another one uh going back
a week uh the uh we have uh this uh
classic audio uh moving coil uh phone
stage if you're not familiar with this
page uh click on reviews on
audiosciencereview.com and you'll see
the latest review so I'm going to work
backwards from
from the this final stage going back and
I'm going to try to go quicker this time
see if we can finish in much less than
an hour
anyway uh this is the phono stage
um and the company name is classic audio
and the gentleman that send it to me is
Michael Fiddler out of UK he builds
every one of these things by hand
assembles all the parts in the UK so
it's gonna cost you a little bit more
money to the tune of 850 us or 650
British pounds
um nice looking package I'm fond of this
sort of white color in aluminum cases
the switches feel good
um so overall it's very nice it's got
some uh interesting features like low
frequency cross feed where it turns the
very low frequencies into mono to cancel
out uh low frequency noise uh kind of
clever scheme there uh switch selectable
gain again this is moving coil only it's
not moving magnets so the gains are
quite high you can select between 63 and
73 DB gain setting depending on the
output of your cartridge back panel is
nice to have upside down fonts so when
you're leaning over you can read the uh
what the uh
um you know what the labels are which is
nice but unusually also has balance
output which I really like as it is we
have a lot of noise on hum issues with
uh fullness stages less eliminated one
stage of it which is the interface
within this and and your pre or power
amplifier the inside of it just
absolutely gorgeous it's almost like a
work of art if you're an engineer you
look at this picture it's like holy cow
somebody really uh went to town to try
to uh build a beautiful looking uh
device even though you don't see it once
the cover is on so quite nice job
um putting it on a stand and feeding it
half a millivolt which is my standard uh
practice we look over here we see no
Distortion components this is our
desired signal no Distortion at all and
we just have a little bit of a Mains
noise it's very hard to eliminate these
things uh gain is so high that it's just
slightest as disturbing picks up some
gain
so combining all this together we get a
sign out of about 73 DB I don't have a
ranking table for phono stages with
moving coil I'll have it for moving
magnet but if you look at my 10 typical
reviews you'll find a sign that's about
50 to 60 is typical
so this is quite a bit cleaner at 73 DB
um so very very nice what is extremely
nice and the company advertises this and
it's good to see that I can confirm it's
just flatness of uh Equalization that's
in there look at how ruler flat this is
and just the variations just stunningly
small so very very very nicely done and
this is one of the most important things
where you know tonality is concerned it
also has a steep high pass filter so get
rid of a low frequency Rumble and noise
of that sort
as we do is overload which is at what
input level would the funnel stage clip
and you can see that it's clipping about
eight millivolts so again remember
typical input is 0.5 so this is able to
tolerate I don't know 15 times more than
the input level nominal input level this
matters because if you have uh noisy uh
um LP and that causes very sharp
transients and you want this to be as as
high as possible typical values I get
before clipping is about five to six
millivolts in in other phono stages here
we're going to eight which is nice and
it's maxed out it's really by 19 volts
output so a pretty serious amount of
voltage coming out of this thing uh your
Preamble power-up May clip actually
before this one does
what is very remarkable is this graph
usually when I run this sweep so that
this one was at one kilohertz but you
know obviously when you play your LP
it's not one killer so I assume it at
different frequencies and you can see
him here he basically doesn't care which
is very very nice and unusual usually as
frequencies go up your Headroom reduces
which is a bad thing because ticks and
pops on on LPA tend to be high frequency
so very very nicely done in here
um if I throw out noise and just measure
Distortion you see Distortion levels are
just extremely good we're talking
digital audio level Distortion we're at
20 kilohertz we're at minus 110 DB or
cyanide of 110 DB if you're familiar
with that term from our attack
measurements on and such uh and it slows
up because of the gain of Equalization
you have to do this so performance
suffers but uh still exceptionally good
so bottom line this is just a fantastic
uh phone station looks good got the
innovation in the feature set and highly
highly recommend it uh and for those of
you in UK and Europe you have a local
supplier which is a great thing to have
next product I reviewed was completely
different it's a Phi OR7
um it's a streaming and local media
player with this what does that mean
um you'd see this the front of it but if
you go in the back you can hook up a
either ethernet cable or you can hook up
your own local storage and uh you can
either play the files locally or you can
play them remotely or if you have a rune
player like I have you can push content
to it it runs uh Android which is nice
which means that you can install
standard Android apps on it and the
display is extremely familiar to anybody
who's using Android phone it's the size
of an Android phone and it's as
responsive as maybe four or five year
old and Android phone which is actually
great A lot of times these streamers and
stuff the technology they use is way way
behind where smartphones are this is
actually quite responsive quite nice
it's got a hard volume control and a
rotary knob to select whether you want
preamp output headphone output or both
um I found this at the volume control
slowly respond excuse me it seems to
bring up some kind of app or something
every time you turn it uh top pop-up
shows up beautiful gorgeous volume
control shows up with graphics and
everything but there's a delay in there
and it doesn't seem to have acceleration
in there so as nice looking as it is I
didn't find that responsive the other
issue with it is that everything is
implemented through an app for example
if you want to connect something to the
coax input you have to run the app that
controls the coax input and sends that
to your output and if you want to do
roon streaming you have to go start the
Rune player to do that other streamers
that usually have button in here or an
app you use that you just switch between
the inputs I didn't get a remote control
with it but company says they have one
and it's pretty cheap seems like it's
like 10 or 15 dollars that may make
things simpler but just note that if you
have to keep switching between modes of
operational inputs it is slow and
somewhat tedious compared to a stream it
just has a button that you pushed and
you go from input to input on this thing
I suspect they've done these apps
because they want to bypass the pipeline
in Android and be able to put bit exact
directly to the uh you know their audio
subsystem that it has uh I'm not sure
about that but it sort of smells that
way another interesting thing is that
what people want to tweak power is you
don't have to use the internal power
supply you can get your own fancy
external power supply hook up to it I
don't see why you want to do that the
internal power supply is fine but for
Tweakers out there you could do that
these products have a million features
my reviews are not about features so
seek out other reviews and to read about
the details of it but what I'll just
explained is sort of the high level gist
of it
um to test it I first tested it with uh
XLR output and coax input it has a gain
setting which for these products usually
only controls the headphone output but
in this device the preamp output out the
back also is controlled by that gain
setting so if you go by the default gain
setting middle of the road the output's
only three volts took me a bit of time
to try to figure out how to get it to
Max up with which is you know setting it
to this Ultra High Gain mode when you do
that that's the output that you get
um we basically a step below state of
the art or fantastic uh distortions a
little bit up noises a little bit up
still these are really good numbers this
is very close to a threshold of hearing
but still you know we're being anal
about performance we land at the top of
the green bucket instead of in a blue
bucket that we want to see in this class
of product zooming in you can see what's
next to it and what have you and what
those products are
um and uh obviously many people buy this
to stream to it as opposed to uh uh
playing with the coax wire like I did so
stream into it you get identical
performance as I would expect uh the
case to be so the inputs don't matter
whether you stream over Network or or
with local playback performance
identical so which is what I already
showed you
um it had incredibly good uh dynamic
range uh and you can see that it's uh
with XLR it sees 122 DBS so more than 20
bits best case music that's out there
it's about 18 bits so you know 2021 bits
this is just superb it's extremely good
dynamic range you can get a little bit
better in state of the art uh Dax but
this is almost up there on that front so
very very good
um uh Jitter response is extremely good
very very low Jitter you can see that
these These are required to be there
everything else in here it's just
basically random noise a bit of Jitter
in here but that's negligible so very
very very clean in here so Jitter is not
a problem whether you're streaming or
using coax by the way so two different
inputs no difference
we get to wonder unfortunate problem uh
about four or five years ago uh I
noticed that just about every new deck
that was coming to the market all of a
sudden now if you sweep the input level
as you increase it all of a sudden
there'd be a new source of distortion
that would then disappear it only
happened these ESS stacks and uh uh sort
of the coined this the ESS IMD hump
because it looks like a camel swamp or
something in the middle near and this
stayed with us for about a year or so
until uh companies started to figure out
how to solve it uh ESS the company was
of no help and poor companies had to
figure it out and once one did the
others did too it's not a complicated
fix just has to do with the loading of
of the deck uh
um buffer stage after it but because ESS
didn't find a fix themselves and has not
advertised it to their licensing Essence
the company makes a DAC chip
um so we get new designs that
unfortunately have the same inflow so
unless the designers you know seeing or
knows about this they're not going to
find it and they need to run this
specific test if you run other tests it
doesn't show up in the dashboard there
was no sign of it but this IMD test is
very very revealing of this problem so
hopefully they can make a revision of
the hardware and get rid of that
linearity is perfect no problems just
textbook flat line which is what we want
to see Distortion by itself uh if you're
at lower levels is extremely good it's
21 bits uh is this noise floor over here
or Distortion floor whatever you want to
call it and it's exceptionally good it's
just one bit away from state of the art
uh it has three filters some dacs have
you know six or eight or nine filters
you don't need them the default is good
enough which is this fast filter in red
um you can see the red one has a nice
flattest response in here there are two
other ones that have you know they
truncate the response don't use those
things they don't do any anything
finally we run a wideband sweep in here
anything less than this blue dashed line
is good and this is very good you see a
flat line meaning that it has no
frequency dependency
it has a headphone amplifier oftentimes
these headphone amps can be a checklist
items with a low power and but that's
not the case in here the performance is
very very good and you get ton of power
it produces almost 0.6 Watts with a 300
ohm load that means just about any
impedance and phone is going to be happy
with this if you go to medium gain you
get this middle line and if you go to
low gain you get the same line with just
less output so no reason to use the low
gain you either use the medium gain
which unfortunately is called The High
game mode even though it's the medium
gay
but you could use either setting you can
even stay in High Gain if you want the
noise penalty is very small
um and if you go to 33 ohm load then it
puts out a lot more power 2.8 Watts so
that's like a little speaker amplifier
and uh it should drive 99 of the
headphones out there with extremely low
noise and Distortion so uh definitely
definitely not a problem there the one
area that was a miss and I can't explain
it the deck stage that I measured had
extremely good dynamic range but when I
tested with this very low output level
of just 50 millivolts
um performance is only 80 DB which is
slightly below average
um this only impacts you if you're using
sensitive iems and they may become some
hiss and Noise
when nothing's playing so overall
performance I would say it's just uh one
notch below state of the art so more
than competent
um and you have a very rich beautiful
display that you do not get the 99 of
the streamers out there that have little
displays or no display you have to keep
using an app with them this is uh quite
functional from that point of view it
looks pretty the display has got very
high contrast nice touch sensitivity so
quite a good option but just know that
there are there's some operational
characteristics it has that you gotta be
happy with when you compare to other
streamers it's very unique the way you
have to sort of start an app to do
anything and just be mindful of that
read other reviews and and download the
manual and and and so forth before you
decide I'm going to recommend it uh
because it's just this competence got
good performance uh on this thing so
moving right along uh the next product I
tested unusual is from topping
um they have a new brand name called TP
and they have a couple of products in
the line there's an amplifier which I
reviewed and this is a corresponding
deck it comes in this configuration
that's got this sort of a rack mount
look and uh and this display that's just
absolutely stunning and gorgeous uh you
know it sort of comes across in here the
beautiful white LEDs extremely
responsive volume control with
acceleration and very large display in
person you just look at this and you
drool this is that nice uh I I like the
large form factor I kind of feel silly
putting desktop products that are only
this big in a big rack uh like my main
system right now I have a topping deck
and it's this big I used to have a
massive Mark Levinson the heck in there
so I feel bad about putting small
devices this is larger nicer
um people look at this they say oh it's
targeted towards Pros it's not targeted
the worst Pros though if you're Pro and
needed that
you could do a far worse than this but
it's not for that use it's not for
touring it's not for live sounds it's
not for any of those things but
certainly so it used to be that in 70s
and 80s high-end audio equipment had
rack mounts and handles and and ears
like this and and I guess they've gone
with with that but mostly I suspect
they've gone with this look because they
can get a case that's basically stamped
Steel
that is cheaper than a typical desktop
product they have which is machine
aluminum so they've had that cost saving
and they pass that down to us so for 229
dollars you're getting this gorgeous
display and you're getting balanced
output uh out of a deck so uh and power
supply is built in so it's very very
neat
um what is the performance performance
is excellent uh just a little bit below
state-of-the-art 1800
118 or so uh uh Cyanide and lenses way
out here and zooming in you can see you
know what this neighborhood uh on this
thing switching to RCA usually you lose
a little bit of performance and you can
see this Mains noise at the start of the
show up in here uh this is the reason
you don't want to use balanced Io if you
can help it look how clean it was with
the balance XLR and just switching to
another connector all of a sudden you
got the spikes which may be worse on on
the system you hook it up to so
um in general you know stay away from
that but transparency is still there
distortions at minus 125 TP so
vanishingly low noise and Distortion uh
on this thing and you can see that we
have 20 bits of dynamic range over RCA
and uh uh sorry over XLR and and almost
as much over RCA uh linearities is
essentially uh perfect a little bit of
jigliness in here but not Material uh
Jitter over uh uh USBS is excellent
there's a tiny bit of Jitter over here
but it's just so low level and and just
hugely inaudible
um over coax and tosling though there's
a significant amount of Jitter visually
it looks horrible but from Level point
of view if you look at this is that
minus 120 DB so below threshold of
hearing it only Rises as we get close to
our main tone and even then it's still
at minus 90 DB or so so due to masking
we're probably not going to hear it a
little bit unfortunate but you know if
you're like me you use USB as your
primary High Fidelity input these
secondary things if you hook them up to
a TV or something for sound out of that
I'm not going to lose sleep over this
would it be nicer if this wasn't there
yes would I pay extra for it probably
not so remember this is you know rag
bound fancy looking balanced deck you
only paying 220 dollars for if you don't
want that pay more and you get a deck
that's cleaner
um look at the same IMD test I was just
showing you that yes as I am the hump
you can see how we don't have it in here
I don't know if this uses the SSO akm
but either either way this is the kind
of performance you want to see
um and look at the Distortion down here
my gosh you know it's 23 bits down it's
almost resolving 24-bit PCM samples it's
just stunningly good uh despite being a
budget product
um we have uh six different uh filters
and default is F3 which is the first one
that I tested it comes down here and uh
you can see how they sort of change
frequent response don't use some of
these karate ones that do this
um and uh wideband performance it could
be a little bit better uh I like like I
said I'd like to have it be less than
this dashed line in here and and it sort
of is there but but again remember
you're paying very low for this balance
tax so overall I like it I vacillated
between saying I like it to hugely like
it eventually I decided to give it the
uh golfing Panther basically because
it's transparent uh it's got a gorgeous
display nice volume control well it's
just hard to say oh wow well you know
this is an average product it is an
exceptional product to have with this
level of performance on this thing it's
not for everybody unfortunately only way
to buy it is on AliExpress because
topping selling it direct without any of
their dealers
um and uh so not convenient to buy that
way but you know if you'd like this kind
of feature set it's it's really a good
product
the last product I'm going to cover and
we have about nine minutes left in my 30
minute budget this is JBL Studio 590.
this is a speaker that costs one
thousand dollars each normally so for a
pair will be two thousand but uh JBL has
this crazy sales once a quarter or so
where the prices are just slashed really
crazy low and I bought it last year for
800 for a pair so I paid less for two of
them than you pay for just buying one
and shipping was included showed up on a
truck and everything these are pretty
tall 70 pound uh speakers
you're seeing it here without this Grill
there's a grip cloth grill that
completely covers this area all the way
down here usually I test them with that
Grill there this time I I didn't and he
bit me in the behind because people came
back and said if you don't use the grill
you have to put a dummy panel in here so
I actually measured it with a grill
again so it's been tested twice so tall
speaker in here and uh for eight hundred
dollars quite low
um it's a 2.5 Wave speaker that means
the two woofers actually have different
frequencies once one of them gets rolled
off with their Twitter the other one is
allowed to play it farther what that
does is that you now have two drivers
that are playing together so you get
very deep bass and you get better
sensitivity in in base Department
downside is that there's a region where
everything's playing so you got the
twitters playing you got the this
welfare flying they got this woofer
playing and then you got the port in the
back also singing all of them combined
and usually create a pretty messy
situation jbl's done a very good job of
keeping that under control so if we look
at in here if you step back the response
you know if I put a red line in there
and say that's the flat response is
actually more or less matching that but
if you focus in you can see okay bases
up it's gone a bit down it's gone a
little bit up there's a lot of
jaggedness there's something going on
here then it sort of goes down goes up
these are all very fine variations your
ear is not sensitive to that level of
variation there's just imagine there's
an averaging that's going on it's not
perfectly precise but you know Tower
speakers that are high performance
they're going to set you back a lot more
than 400 each that paid for this uh on
this thing as I said people complain
that you need to measure with the grill
or with the dummy panel so I've measured
it again the same two-day testing went
on and I should with it without the
Grille and the green is is the original
measurement I just showed you and black
is a new one is basically making no
difference they're just the smallest
tiniest bit of difference and some of
that could be because I took the speaker
off and put it back again and it could
be slightly different positions so
really the grill is transparent you
could have it on or not have it on
the early Reflections looks good other
than we have a dip in here and that's
caused by uh floor bounce the most and
so if you have a thick carpet you can
put in there uh you could basically
smooth that out otherwise it's got a
decent slope and if we combine all the
measurements and predict what the
in-room response will be we can see that
it's pretty good that's about what we
want to see
with a hole in the middle like that
I mentioned that there are all these
drivers playing and you can see the
response of all of them individuals
they're actually two ports in the back
these are the two ports
there are two woofers this is one woofer
this is the other woofer and there's a
Twitter in here so all of these things
have to be corralled and brought
together they have a smooth flat
response so they've actually done a very
good job of taming all this with all
these resonances from the port in there
acting up
um that large waveguide that's around
that horn uh it actually provides very
smooth control directivity so that's
quite good and we can see that in here
horizontally so the side Reflections are
going to be good and I suggest not
absorbing those vertically it's not
great but neither is you know 90 of the
speakers you have out there unless
they're coaxial uh the one area really
stands out is distortion
in bass is actually extremely good
because those dual woofers power
handling is great and we don't get a lot
of social but unfortunately between one
two uh three kilohertz we actually have
a hump in there and that's where hearing
is most sensitive and then there's this
sharp resonance at higher frequencies uh
the Twitter is resonating and that's at
86 we go to 96 all of a sudden it gets
really really crazy up here uh you don't
want to see this kind of thing as narrow
it resonances so you gotta have the
right notes in the music to hit it to to
cause problems but it is quite high so
um
where you know what is the cause of this
we the mid-range area this could be
either from the bottom of the Twitter or
it could be from upper half of the uh
woofer response so I went ahead and and
got the Distortion from either one of
the from from those ports independently
and you can see that the Twitter also
has Rising Distortion Twitter still they
don't like to play very low and if you
force them to play low the Distortion
increases and on the woofer we have a
sharp resonance that comes out of the
one that is not crossed over and so
combine these two together and you get
this gonna respond so that's why you
know we have it so basically both of
them have problems in that area
um and uh you can if you want to look at
them as absolute level you can see the
sudden rise uh on this thing so it is
second harmonic so masking probably
helps a lot in not hearing it but
although it's been equal you don't want
to have this gonna rise on a speaker
um the resonances show up in many
measurements we can see two of them
showing up over here in the impedance
graph even and a lot more of it showing
up in in CSD waterfall whenever there's
a sharp little spike in here you can see
a corresponding uh time domain ringing
this goes on uh even a step response you
can see his little jaggedness in here
rather than sort of smooth drop off
so when I measured this speaker my
impression was gonna have problems and
I'm probably not gonna like it that's
how I went into a listening test now I
should tell you that it's not a normal
listening test in that 95 of the time I
put speakers in my Listening Room which
you don't see in here but it's for my
two channel system is and it's the exact
same spot every speaker goes very
controlled and it's got a ceiling above
it that's closer so it's some I'm very
very familiar when it's calibrated as
far as the environment the speaker has
been 70 pounds was back breaking lifting
it all the time and uh so I didn't want
to Lug it up to my lab which is two
floors up and so I just measured in our
living room and I've done that with some
other large heavy speakers and so a
little bit of you know it's just gonna
speak it's gonna sound different it's a
massive speak space the ceiling here is
35 40 foot high so very very different
space so I can't make absolute judgments
about the sound but I got I tell you as
soon as I started playing this speaker I
mean scroll down to the listener as soon
as I started playing it you get this
sound which I described that you get you
only get out of tower speakers where the
image that they portray is large and
tall and Twitter's up and the other
drivers are low and there's a realism
that goes with that number one and
number two the bass response is deep and
has no Distortion when I play my track
to have sub bass in them
um typical bookshelf so you speak it
either doesn't play it at all or plays a
faint version with a lot of distortion
here you heard the sub Bass with no
Distortion and just a little bit faints
and that sub bass I think is around 25
30 Hertz so very very impressive very
clean very nice
um for the rest of the tracks I that was
played nothing jumped out at me as
sounding fantastic
um my ears were plugged at that time
they still are at summertime they're
allergies like we spend more time
outside here and uh so you know and I
from experience when my ears are plugged
that way I tend to not enjoy sound as
well as I do when they're not black so
take away with a grain of salt but you
know nothing was bad nothing jumped out
at me there was nothing to EQ there are
not no large anomalies to go after
there's responses more or less flat from
that point of view so I didn't try to EQ
it so where is it net out basically to
me at 400 each that I paid for as a
steal is a fantastic thing I mean you're
not gonna get too nearly well designed
uh speakers for four hundred dollars
each uh delivered to your door uh at
full one thousand dollars each it gets a
little bit more difficult I would think
about it I would look at other options I
would see if I can stretch my budget a
little bit more get to twenty five
hundred three thousand dollars and get
it really the next level up uh speaker
on this thing but otherwise at this
price which is routinely on sale this
price is a very good offer
I have for you we stuck to our 30-minute
budget hopefully you liked it uh we'll
see you on a future video bye-bye